este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a sur
shark luego os doy más detalles pero
antes vamos con nuestra historia de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta cuál es el
arma más cara de la historia pues no no
es ninguna bomba atómica ni tampoco la
cúpula antimisiles de israel el arma más
cara de toda la historia es el caza de
combate f-35 lightning 2
[Música]
ah
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
sobre todo los que estéis familiarizados
con este tema fonseca no es verdad hay
aviones de combate mucho más caros que
el f-35 por ejemplo un f-22 puede costar
unos 300 millones de dólares por unidad
mientras que el f-35 lightning 2 puede
costar menos de 80 millones de dólares
pero lo que hace que este avión sea tan
increíblemente caro es el coste para
desarrollarlo agarrados a la silla
porque la cifra os va a dejar temblando
400 mil millones de dólares para que os
hagáis una idea eso es más que todo el
pib de un país tan grande como egipto la
estación espacial internacional que
tampoco es que saliera barata
precisamente costó solamente 150 mil
millones de dólares pero esperad un
momento porque esto no es todo cuando
hablamos de gasto militar normalmente
nos olvidamos de una parte muy
importante el mantenimiento es decir el
coste de tener todos los de 35 listos
para el combate reparaciones combustible
actualizaciones pues bien si contamos
todo esto podemos decir que el coste
total del f-35 supera los 1,1 billones
de dólares y 6 digo billones en
castellano en inglés sería trillones
sería el coste para eeuu en las próximas
décadas si os habéis perdido con las
cifras pensando así por un momento es
más de la mitad de todo el último
presupuesto de la unión europea
presupuesto que por cierto hemos
criticado varias veces aquí en visual
político porque nos parece una auténtica
de gasto público pues bien en este
caso hablamos de una auténtica salvajada
sólo para desarrollar este caza de
combate que veis en pantalla
a
[Aplausos]
y por supuesto aunque lo haya
desarrollado una empresa privada no os
equivoquéis todo ese dinero viene del
bolsillo de los contribuyentes tanto los
de eeuu como los de otros países como
reino unido países bajos y otros tantos
aliados luego os explicaré por qué y
ahora lo que os estáis preguntando todos
espero tener merece la pena gastarse
tanto dinero de verdad es tan increíble
este f-35 pues esta es la misma pregunta
que se llevan haciendo en washington
durante años desde john mccain hasta
donald trump muchos políticos
estadounidenses han criticado duramente
el programa del f-35 y la polémica
continúa veréis seguro que todos os
habéis preguntado muchas veces si de
verdad es tan importante el gasto
militar especialmente los que veáis este
vídeo desde eeuu por supuesto que nadie
en su sano juicio cuestiona que todos
los países necesitan un ejército pero
hacia dónde va tantísimo gasto público
en eeuu porque el proyecto del f-35 ha
costado tanto dinero cómo funciona el
mercado del armamento ha sido una buena
o una mala idea atentos porque a través
del f-35 vamos a aprender muchas cosas
en este vídeo sobre el mundo del
armamento porque hoy vamos a responder a
todas estas juntas pero antes antes de
hablar de defensa y seguridad para un
país vamos a hablar de defensa y
seguridad para tu ordenador o tu
teléfono móvil cómo podemos evitar la
mayoría de los hackers por internet cómo
podemos proteger nuestra privacidad en
la red exacto usando una vpn y cuál es
la vpn favorita de visual política lo
sabéis todos los que sois veteranos
seguidores de este canal sur shark vpn
kursat vpn no sólo nos permite ver webs
de cualquier país además nos permite
hacerlo sin miedo llenar nuestro
ordenador o nuestro móvil de virus y
creedme el tema de la ciberseguridad se
lo toma muy en serio por ejemplo se usar
tiene una herramienta que se llama link
web que bloquea todos esos pasos de
propaganda por donde se cuelan un montón
de bots y de cookies que francamente no
queremos tener por si todo esto fuera
poco con una única cuenta de surf shark
podrás registrar todos los dispositivos
que quieras quieres navegar con
seguridad desde tu smartphone o desde tu
móvil o desde tu ordenador pues puedes
hacer todo esto con una única cuenta de
surf shark vpn y por supuesto tenemos
una oferta muy especial para todos
vosotros que seguís visual política si
utilizáis el código político terminado
en que podréis disfrutar de un 80 3 por
ciento de descuento más tres meses extra
totalmente gratuitos tenéis todos los
enlaces en la descripción no esperéis
más y descargados ya la aplicación y
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
un caza para unirlos a todos
puede que se sorprenda pero la idea
inicial del f-35 era ahorrar gastos tal
cual como lo es nuestra historia empieza
en los años 90 la guerra fría había
terminado y esto significaba que ya no
había un gigante como la unión soviética
con el que competir en la carrera
armamentística así que tanto el ejército
americano como muchos otros ejércitos
aliados decidieron optimizar costes al
menos en los cazas de combate como pues
primero uniendo fuerzas para desarrollar
un único caza para todos estos países es
decir eeuu reino unido canadá o países
bajos junto a muchos otros aliados se
unieron para crear el joint strike
fighter program podríamos decir que este
programa era algo así como una carta a
santa claus con todas las condiciones
que tenía que tener este nuevo caza de
combate esta forma podían hacer un
pedido mucho más grande a la empresa
proveedora y al hacer un pedido más
grande se generaba una economía de
escala y se podían abaratar costes tiene
sentido verdad
[Música]
y qué diríais que pusieron en esta carta
a los reyes magos pues para optimizar
aún más los costes hicieron algo
parecido a lo que años más tarde harían
las empresas de vuelos 'low cost' como
por ejemplo ryanair usar un único modelo
de avión que sirviera para todo porque
si mis queridos compañeros de la
comunidad de visual política da caza de
combate está pensado para un uso muy
concreto por ejemplo los harrier son
unos aviones fantásticos para dar apoyo
a tropas de tierra porque pues porque
entre otras muchas cosas pueden
aterrizar y despegar de forma vertical
como si fueran un helicóptero eso
permite operar en casi todo tipo de
zonas sin embargo un harrier nos sirve
para atacar otros aviones de combate
porque no puede alcanzar velocidad
supersónica así que si quieres estar
listo para combates aire-aire necesitas
también una flota de por ejemplo
f-16 eso significa que necesitas tener
ingenieros de mantenimiento y recambio
de cada uno de los distintos modelos de
caza conclusión una auténtica fortuna
[Música]
el plan maestro del ejército era un caza
para unirlos a todos un avión
todoterreno que pudiera uno romper la
barrera del sonido' dos aterrizar y
despegar perfectamente y tres y más
importante que fuera furtivo es decir
que ningún radar lo pudiera detectar por
supuesto que ya en los años 90 había
aviones que tenían alguna de estas
características pero juntar las tres en
un único que hace de combate era un
prodigio nunca visto pues bien con esta
carta santa claus se convocó un concurso
al que se presentaron en las empresas
armamentísticas más importantes del
mundo y finalmente en el año 2001 el
jurado nombró al ganador atentos el
equipo de lockheed martin gana la
competición del joint strike fighter que
dados con el nombre de esta empresa
lockheed martin desde que ganaron el
concurso el precio de sus acciones se ha
multiplicado por seis
[Música]
y pensando bien lockheed martin ha
desarrollado un avión pensado para
sustituir a casi todas las flotas de
cazas de combate de eeuu y aliados para
que os hagáis una idea solo el pentágono
ha hecho un pedido de más de 2.400 cazas
es decir que ganar este contrato fue un
auténtico boom para la empresa pero
también fue en este momento cuando
empezó la pesadilla del f-35
[Música]
el arma más cara de la historia
el f-35 lightning 2 ya estaba a punto de
hacerse realidad lo que en martín había
diseñado un avión que lo tenía todo era
furtivo supersónico y podía despegar y
aterrizar verticalmente y además tenía
el último grito en software y para eso
tanto eeuu como el resto de países
aliados que formaban parte del programa
les pusieron 298 mil millones de dólares
en la mesa puede parecer mucho dinero
pero recordad que hablamos de renovar
casi toda la flota de cazas de combate
el problema el problema vino a la hora
de fabricarlo en masa
[Música]
de entrada no había un único modelo de f
35 en realidad había tres el f 35
para combate aéreo el f 35b para
aterrizaje y despegue vertical y el f-35
ce que tendría alas plegables y que
estaba pensado y está pensado para
operaciones de rescate en principio
ambos aviones iban a ser muy parecidos
pero a medida que avanzaba la producción
empezaron a surgir pequeñitos problemas
principalmente con el software
conclusión los distintos modelos de f-35
no son tan parecidos entre sí y en
muchos casos necesitan personal
especializado para su mantenimiento pero
ojalá éste fuera el único problema
la idea de lockheed martin era lo que se
llama desarrollo concurrente y diréis y
esto qué significa pues que en lugar de
esperar a tener todos los diseños listos
para producirlos en masa la empresa
empieza a fabricar aviones en versión
beta y luego a medida que avanzan los
del departamento de i + d se van
haciendo mejoras en los aviones que ya
se han fabricado la idea de esta
estrategia era producir más rápido pero
produjo el resultado contrario
[Música]
cada vez que se iban a introducir
mejoras nuevas en estos aviones versión
beta aparecían nuevos problemas y todos
estos problemas se traducían en dos
cosas retrasos y dinero
muchísimo dinero atentos
el coste del programa del f-35 sube a
406 mil 600 millones de dólares en la
última estimación habéis oído bien lo
que en principio no llegaba a los 300
mil millones de dólares que ojo ya es
dinero ha terminado superando los 400
mil y aquí hay interpretaciones para
todos los gustos por supuesto hay quien
dice que todo estos son problemas
comprensibles pero no son pocos quienes
se quejan de la falta de incentivos de
la empresa es decir de lockheed martin
para optimizar gastos a fin de cuentas
porque iban a hacerlo una vez se les ha
adjudicado el contrato y se ha empezado
a gastar el dinero nadie va a cortar el
proyecto en seco sería tirar a la basura
toda la inversión así que tanto eeuu
como el resto de aliados se han visto
obligados a seguir pagando todos los
sobrecostos para al menos poder tener de
una vez por todas ese ansiado f-35
pero aquí no termina la cosa en la c-35
no solo es claro en su desarrollo
también en el mantenimiento y en el uso
porque por ejemplo volar un caza f 15 x
cuesta unos 28 mil dólares por hora un f
35 cuesta más de 45 mil dólares por hora
dicho de otra forma que si será un café
increíble pero hay que pensárselo dos
veces antes de ponerlo a volar y ahora
dos preguntas que seguro que os estaréis
haciendo la primera existen ya 35 en uso
pues si después de una infinidad de
retrasos en el año 2015 salieron los
primeros f-35 listos para el combate sin
embargo todavía hoy más de 20 años
después de que lo que martín ganar el
contrato quedan todavía miles de aviones
por terminar así que la segunda pregunta
es de verdad ha merecido la pena gastar
tantísimo dinero pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
un supercomputador con alas
esto que veis en pantalla es una de las
partes más importantes del f-35 el casco
para que os hagáis una idea cada uno de
estos cascos vale más de 400 mil dólares
es decir es más caro incluso que un
ferrari y grace pero qué tiene de
especial el dichoso casco pues entre
otras cosas permite que el piloto vuele
el avión como si fuera una alfombra
mágica es decir que puede ver el
exterior del avión sin el fuselaje todo
esto es gracias a los muchísimos radares
que lleva el f-35 en el exterior no es
un caza cualquiera es un supercomputador
con alas y por lo que dicen los que lo
han pilotado es una auténtica maravilla
de hecho en muchos casos se pueden
incluso dar órdenes por voz es decir es
como si tuviera el siri o el ok google
de los teléfonos móviles pero versión
militar y no sólo eso los f-35
recolectan toda la información y la
comparten tanto con el apoyo en tierra
como con otros aviones f-35 y esto es
una auténtica revolución en los cazas no
hace falta que os diga que pilotar un
caza de combate es
complicadísimo
[Música]
por un lado los mandos de cabina están
llenos de botones y de pantallas a las
que hay que prestar atención pero
recordad que no solo estamos volando
también estamos en combate es decir que
hay que estar pendiente de volar y a la
vez de detectar al enemigo y dispararle
antes de que él nos disparé nosotros
vamos una auténtica locura pues bien el
f-35 procesa toda la información de los
radares y envía a órdenes claras y
directas al piloto es más incluso puede
compartir información con tanques o
baterías de misiles o incluso otros
cazas f-35 de esta forma se puede
triangular de forma automática dónde
está por ejemplo un radar enemigo
entendéis ahora porque el software del
f-35 daba tantos problemas es una parte
fundamental de este caza de combate
podemos decir que el f-35 no es sólo un
avión es todo un sistema para compartir
información de forma automática en el
campo de combate es big data aplicado a
la guerra y por supuesto a todo esto hay
que sumarle el hecho de ser un avión
furtivo todos los modelos de f-35 son
capaces de volar sin apenas ser
detectados por ningún radar ni ninguna
cámara de calor y esto es todo un
prodigio técnico pensad que un motor de
un avión supersónico tiende a calentarse
evitar en la cámara de calor requiere un
auténtico prodigio de la ingeniería
dicho de otra forma es el f-35 un buen
avión la respuesta es sí de hecho se
dice que tendrá una vigencia de más de
40 años es decir que para el año 2060
seguiremos oyendo hablar de los f 35
lightning 2 y la pregunta que os
estaréis haciendo todos ahora es qué
impacto va a tener el f-35 en la guerra
moderna pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
una señal para china
toda la información que tenemos en este
momento se puede decir que el f-35 no
tiene rival en el mundo lo más parecido
a este caza de combate sería el j-20
chino pero por lo que dicen los expertos
no es ni de lejos tan impresionante como
el f-35 ojo existen cazas más rápidos o
con mejor capacidad de maniobra por
ejemplo el f-22 es muy superior en
muchas cosas ahora bien el f-22 es un
caza que sólo está disponible para eeuu
y que cuesta más de 300 millones por
unidad dicho de otra forma el f-35 está
destinado a ser el caza de referencia de
casi todos los aliados del 'tío sam'
[Música]
de hecho ni siquiera eeuu fue el primer
país en utilizarlo en combate los
primeros en estrenar el f-35 fueron los
israelíes pero por encima de todo lo más
importante de este nuevo y flamante caza
de combate es que es toda una señal para
china y
singapur está en la etapa final para
adquirir 4 f-35 que serán entregados a
finales del 2026 eeuu da luz verde japón
para comprar el f-35 por valor de 23.000
millones de dólares japón singapur corea
del sur todos estos son países de asia
que están renovando sus flotas de
aviación con armamento de eeuu armamento
con el que al menos que se sepa china
todavía no puede competir todo esto
cumple un objetivo los países que rodean
a china se están armando para evitar o
disuadir una posible expansión del
gigante asiático y lo hacen reforzando
sus lazos militares con eeuu dicho de
otra forma que el f-35 está ayudando a
que el 'tío sam' mantenga sus aliados en
asia lo mismo ocurre en europa donde
casi todos los países de la otan han
comprado o se están planteando comprar
f-35 para renovar sus flotas de cazas
por supuesto que todavía quedan unos
pocos años para que lockheed martin
entregue todos los pedidos que le han
hecho y todavía hoy especialmente con la
situación de la pandemia del cob y nos
encontramos con un montón de problemas
de retrasos pero podemos decir que los
735 se están convirtiendo en el objeto
de deseo de casi todos los ejércitos del
mundo al menos los ejércitos de los
aliados de eeuu así que ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros queréis que
eeuu va a hacer un buen negocio
vendiendo el f-35 a sus aliados aunque
sea en el largo plazo habría sido
posible desarrollar este caza de combate
por menos dinero es posible de verdad
controlar los gastos de la industria
militar podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios y como siempre no
olvidéis que aquí en visual politics
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribimos este canal y dadle
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]